hey everybody what's going on welcome to
stream coco
it's just us today guys just us
me and my glasses and my dopey mad shirt
uh and you uh fleurgan splurging good to
see you find a life 2016. uh that's what
i'm trying to do in 2017. wheezy949 uh
lamissa what's up we're gonna be playing
a little resident evil today we're gonna
have a nascar driver on but
unfortunately i can't last minute um so
oh my goodness that live chat on the
right who's that on the right is that is
that youtube on the right i love it i
love it we got our intern riley uh
working the boards so it's gonna be
interesting today don't [ __ ] up riley
don't [ __ ] this up don't [ __ ] this up
hey riley can you make the the chat on
the right a little bit bigger because my
old man eyes can't see so well uh guys
welcome to stream coco today we're gonna
play a little resident evil 7 which i've
been playing on my own uh if you joined
us last night
on twitch.tv aaron blair uh we uh saw a
lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] i shot a lot of
eyeballs out of uh a bunch of weird
tentacles it was crazy
at work i'm way
far back so i thought instead we play a
little
band footage a little extra content now
for the people who haven't played who
have played resident evil 7 is this
gonna spoil the game for me
the arium what's up how's it going jeff
tag what's up
jeff tag just says trump i love it
um
is
this is is is is this gonna ruin the
game you guys hook me up because i don't
want
to ruin my game
uh if this is gonna ruin the game so
he gots to lets me know uh
so happy you're doing this hey double
plus good games good to see you more
resident evil
uh smell the couch why
probably not really says quantum
epiphany yeah i cannot watch your
private streams it's still bedtime for
me at that moment sorry andy it will
spoil it all right it'll spoil it it'll
spoil it no it's not no it's not god
damn it why do i ask the chat anything
it's just like come on you dicks no go
for it no
uh it it which one do i plan on playing
no chris sacha don't worry elite spider
go go go do it did i play pt yes esteban
i played pt
is it gonna ruin it is it gonna ruin it
her lymph node is fine fleurgensbergen
beth is all right
is this gonna ruin it this is gonna ruin
the game for me somebody's just for
god's steaks no stop
thank you friends you're a cool guy too
so how to code it for me i will watch me
a journey i i love you i it's a the
royal dicks it's fine says quantum
epiphany quite epiphany i trust your
opinion
i'm going to play the band footage let's
do it
because i want something new that's
going to be scary but i don't you know
want it to ruin [ __ ]
following notifications on double plus
good games thanks man
ah
wait
ooh
play nightmare otherwise known as
live my real life bring back my oh
beth's in the other room
banned footage is short prequels okay
daria
devarious lord devarious what does that
mean lord davarius
uh actually per uh
cyprus
uh yes i have played the new doom i
actually did a
um
a clueless gamer on the new doom for the
super bowl not this past super bowl but
the one before with josh norman and
super bowl mvp
von miller uh which you can find at um
youtube.com coolestgamer
i'm sorry teamcoco.com coolestgaming
uh
that's right
it's the new doom is so fun it's really
really great it's like it changes your
brain chemistry to make you
a crazier more intense
human being
where am i
oh you know what
let's do this thing called
putting on
the
oh let's do this thing called putting on
the no let's do this thing called
putting on the subtitles
game makers put subtitles under the same
thing always what are we doing guys come
on it's hard to find though long stories
is devarious it's something like a
prequel hey tara tara missus what's up
your what's up alfred 13th not you again
old man says multidirt one two three
four
ooh nanak conan
conan's in his office he might stop by
later he might not i don't know guys i
don't know
we'll see
it's a surprise even to me so there you
go
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
all right where am i in the garage
survive until dawn great
wait is all this stuff oh i have to buy
[ __ ]
oh come on all right well
you know i go knife of course
good old knife i mean i guess we're
gonna go shotgun
a handgun
oh let's get some first aid right
hand gun
and gun ammo
all right let's see what we got
oh man you guys i hate this game
i don't need the music by the way
what is this
safety first
oh my god this is horrifying
what is this
dudes
i hate this
whatever you do don't die thanks corey
uh
okay can i just stay in this room
oh you know what i noticed there are no
doors by the way
because you could stop uh the monsters
in this game you can stop with doors
man i hate this game
oh god
oh [ __ ]
let's not go that way
ah jesus
let's get out of here
is this just gonna be like a thousand
monsters coming after me what the
come on man
there's no art to this
what is this thing
oh there we go
oh that's fun
oh my god jesus
this is impossible
this is impossible there's too many of
them
what am i supposed to do here
this sucks
so i'm just locked down in this basement
this is great
this is awful
man this blows come on
pretty much yay
pt was great but i don't think you could
play pt anymore right they took it off
the thing
oh there's definitely something here i
remember this
well this sucks
cool
i mean there's
just there's just monsters forever what
the [ __ ]
[Music]
well here's my shitty gun that does
absolutely nothing
this will be great
come to the coast they say we'll have a
couple laughs they say
yeah i got old i'm conan guys and i got
really old
can i just take a quick breather here
pal or uh
[Music]
oh i see
i'm trying to survive
oh that's cool oh great this is cool
this is cool
this is cool so glad this is happening
i see i see i have to hit the scrap
thing
oh let's go under this
great let's run to your own [ __ ]
traps shut up riley
yeah
oh boy oh we're in trouble kids we're in
some trouble here
i've definitely had better days
yeah i'm trying dude
do you think
at least they have terrible aim
[Music]
oh come on load the gun you idiot oh
geez
oh geez
oh geez oh geez
oh boy
i'm so ft
start the scrap any chance you get
coming over watching review some game
some episodes of power rangers i don't
know maybe
come up to my wire truck hey that's not
cool he came through the wire trap not
cool not cool
uh thanks carrie now that was awful
i think the mold wants a kiss this
desert broke tiger
all right well
i survived one hour that was only a
fifth
oh this is oh i get some pity scrap
thanks game
uh
oh i can block oh that's right read by
nature thank you we're definitely gonna
need a death counter andy that's true
sarana hello
colin john yeah sorry dylan i know i do
like your smiley faces though all right
here we go
here we go okay machine gun set nerve
gas traps ooh i like where this is going
flammable drums
all right let's go
yes try again all right we got this
thank you goat legend 04 i'm gonna kill
the [ __ ]
story mod uh hey corky pants uh hey juan
what's up grenade launcher jose jose
arroyo
that can't be the real jose arroyo
okay we can skip this we can skip this
we don't care about this part
sarana everybody wants to know where
beth is she's in her office hey harona
although this guy knows exactly where he
is right now
all right here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna start this
start the scrap machine
okay here's what we're gonna get first
aid of course let's get a couple of
those puppies
i think we just got shocked you know
knife fine i think we just go shotgun
and just go straight in right we don't
care about anything
right but i guess we need the corrosive
all right this is what we're gonna do
all right [ __ ]
what's up let's set up some trap
let's set some traps up too oh you know
what i shouldn't have used all that
i got to set these traps up
can i just stay here and just kill them
as they come forward i can right
that's a good idea right
there's two options when fighting
zombies which these basically are
there's the flight option which is like
keep moving so you can't uh you can't
ever get uh
you know like pinned in you know i had
this conversation with robert kirkman
actually on the team coco podcast
uh which you can find at teamcoco.com
podcast so robert kirkman i talked about
there's two things there's the there's
the flight which is just you keep moving
all the time
or
oh it's behind me that's kind of cheap
cheap
cheap
cheap
your dick your dick you guys suck
yeah sucks to have a thing in the head
doesn't it
yeah there we go baby
we got a turret in the house
i love this
well well well what do we have here
let's start this scrap thing going
uh this is a challenge rockarolla this
is uh we're playing the band footage the
first episode which is like a prequel
which is basically just kill as many
things as you possibly can
all the time
that turret is dope btw anyway kirk and
i talked about there's fight or flight
so there's fight which is
you can constantly um
you can you can constantly be moving
constantly on the
and never get trapped
or there's also
fight which is like you try to hole up
you suck you suck you suck
uh you try to hole up
and wait for uh
get out of my way hey
or you try to hold up and defend
yourself that way
[Music]
ooh i wonder if i can just can i run out
the does the clock happen on the menu
can i just run out the clock this way
1500
uh
how many shotgun shells i got
you're a dick
i think we're in some trouble
let's move this way let's stay close to
that turret man that thing is this thing
is dope
what's the shooting at what's it
shooting at
it's scary when a turret shooting is
something you don't see
let's go over here get some more scrap
oh there's a weird honey baked ham
hey they're good looking
what do you got what do you got what do
you got
oh dude this turret is my best and only
friend in this game by the way
uh
i hate this game oh we got a turret now
i love this well you know look
it's always nice to have a friend i was
feeling alone
going google conan images for what
i gotta keep moving for this one the
scrap machines are all over you gotta
trap some turrets all right fine i'm
gonna keep moving
thanks for the tips
uh i feel we feel good about this right
i think we're pretty good prob's not
play
i don't think it works that way banned
footage nice call figure it out through
the xbox one you need to chat on my
phone another time uh thanks killer
sniper
well if conan had a machine gun and mold
a machine gun a shotgun and mold zombies
it would be a much more interesting show
i'll give you that
keep moving baby
ah [ __ ]
jesus christ
i hate those things [ __ ]
this game is still scary how's this game
still scaring me oh [ __ ] you
god damn it
oh oh these guys those things suck
die you
jesus christ
oh my god ah [ __ ] where's my turret
where's my pal the turret kill this oh
compactors have stopped come on
[Music]
load it up load it up
level max what
unable to create
damn it
oh those things suck
where's the stupid scrap thing i'm not
dying down here
[Music]
dude is it better than the controller
get worse if you play it connects to the
console no it gets better and this was
out so uh
this was out of uh juice so i had to
hook it up
compactors restarted great
why did the compactor stop by the way
that's my question
i can get the corrosive baby
so should we go
shall we go upstairs y'all
i think i'm gonna
keep it together we survived this far
yeah kit bro
[ __ ] where's the upstairs man
[Music]
is it this way
how come i just saw it a second ago
it's this way into the left right here
it is
yeah
corrosive it up
sweet now i mean an even worse room ah
go home monster you're drunk
damn it
great
great this is going really well
getting gang-banged by a bunch of mold
monsters
oh jesus christ all right dude [ __ ]
keep your [ __ ] loaded
oh you suck
you're the worst thanks
i do love in this game how putting
just [ __ ] on your hand makes you all
better
there's one in here right let's start
this baby going
this music sucks
why can't i get the m37 what's the m37
this is the m37
jesus
wow
how could i miss that come on blair oh
you ass
you idiot
okay not enough scrap great
[Music]
who i am in
trouble kids
i'm in some serious
do do as they call it
don't have a lot of bullets and
i have lost my way which is great
that's what you want when you're in a
scary basement to lose your way
okay definitely more of those for show i
bet the molds smell very nice i know you
know what this is probably bad for my
respiratory uh
upgrade your guns you say
how do i upgrade my guns anybody know
this game looks so slow face spray your
face step
stop wasting parts on traps okay
oh thanks gold that's very nice resident
sleeper so all right so what what should
i be doing here how do i
oh wait
oh there's skills over here oh
blurts
oh you [ __ ]
what am i doing
oh defeat jack
[Music]
how am i gonna defeat jack dude
i don't have like the amount of
[ __ ] it's gonna take to defeat jack
uh jack
please leave me alone
[Music]
oh
that really hurt me a lot
okay okay
how am i supposed to defeat this guy in
the game
it takes like a thousand things
no i'm not
[Music]
there's no way i can kill this guy
there's no way it's not going to happen
i'm dead there's no way there's no how
am i supposed to kill jack
the baker is very hard to kill are you
guys aware of that yes fourth wave i'm
very aware of it
yeah i know
revlio
he's playing with me
how am i supposed to kill jack shoot him
in the balls
show him your skills i got no skills
oh
i can get a machine gun
god damn
repeated shotgun bullets that's just it
huh
i guess i got a block
casual couch day man of course
all right let's try it again
and then maybe we'll go uh then maybe
we'll go into the game itself what do
you guys think
all right let's see
how about i try to save the auto turret
the problem of the auto turret is it's
like a that it's like a thousand block
block block
yeah unicorn i will say hi to thing fox
in the hair the more you play the more
you can do all right
one more time we're gonna try this one
more time here we go
and then we're just gonna go play the
game
or should we try the bedroom dlc
we could we could try the better yes
anyway
thanks elite crew
i've been playing i've been playing the
mate let's uh
let's see if we have the other band
footage downloaded you can try that
alright let's play bedroom
[Music]
ethan must die is also fast paced
oh clancy again yes my boy clancy clancy
was when you play the normal game clancy
is a cameraman who gets absolutely
completely railed and then later you
play as clancy and it's just absolutely
you get it's horrifying what happens
with lansing
that woman caught him and shoved
something strong under his nose man
clancy just gets it
uh yeah read by nature maybe on the
christie i'll see you when it releases
outdoor new england i'm gonna i'm gonna
be asking for your help so stay close
hey petey highlighter
railed you know like uh just
like completely killed did anyone say
railed nailed no
just takes lots of practice oh rick
loves bacon
i wish i had the time here we go
for people haven't played resident evil
7 it's super fun block more i will i
will farkas chill out
mama wanted you to stay in the baby
chair interesting
oh not this
[ __ ] again ah
our daughter really likes you
she wants you to be your big brother
gross oh now don't get too excited
don't jump up and down just yet
you want to be part of this family you
gotta eat like family uh no thanks nope
why do i feel like she's gonna give me
something gross to eat smells good don't
it
no it actually doesn't it smells
disgusting you eat all this and you can
be one of us
then i'll take those things off and you
can go out and play
but you gotta eat all of it
uh
[Music]
i'm not eating it it smells like [ __ ]
because that's probably what i'm
supposed to say right
not eating that it smells like [ __ ]
i'm on a chef priority only diet thank
you
sounds like your love expired about two
weeks ago
you better behave yourself now don't
tell me how to live how about that
escape from the room
isn't it always
well first of all what we're going to do
is
blood on screen
oh i want to do more let's do that
let's do camera wobble on right um let's
make it brighter man
too freaking dark oh is this too bright
it's too bright i made it too bright i
went too far
that's fine
all right here we go i gotta do
something
dope watched what is that vestal nixon
he didn't die boundary issues this class
was
dylan glad you're liking it
meow says she's a hottie well you know
different strokes for different folks
kids
all right so let's look around here
same time as all the other clocks
oh
lighter they'll come in handy
nail polish love that purple
strong pull might open it i have one of
these uh tupperware things by the way
they're great
more blood trying k miller i put the
most amount of blood which is normal
this is interesting
well clearly untitled painting c goes
here kids
what am i stupid
don't answer that
all right
let's wait to open the book all hail
caesar
they're a fan of cone brothers
okay
i mean i've been in a room like this
before
and the answer was 10 15 so
guys this is like an escape room only
you'll die if you don't get out who here
has done has anybody done an escape room
because that stuff is fun
oh
horrifying gross
spider things
good
[ __ ] i'm not touching that [ __ ]
well i certainly have to burn them out
right
i'm not gonna eat it am i don't eat it
don't eat it no don't eat it oh i didn't
want to eat it
i want to see if i can pick some up and
throw it on the spiders you idiot
god now i'm gonna be one of those things
those mold monster things
oh crap
use the lighter on it all right scock
let's see if we can use the lighter
all right right sorry i'm done
[ __ ] i'm not touching that
zero escape series what's that net
positive what's the zero escape series
need to be done here
well let's see what the clock is now the
other clock stuff all said 10 15.
is that a key
hey it's a snake it's our old pal the
snake key
you find a disgusting body
in the game oh one of these all right
well figure that out
what's going on here
i don't get the cork thing
huh
and diarrhea for days is he whizzy but
you know what my secret is that's my
secret cap i always have diarrhea
can't give a guy diarrhea if he's
already got it outsmarted you resident
evil
sucker
all right well
let's see what
time clock is this i bet it's 10 15.
walk from the side of course there's got
to be another way out of here there's
got to be another way out of here jesus
relax dude
so you got captured by a crazy family
you're gonna be just fine you know what
let's can we light this other
thing
like the other candle nope why do we
want to do that
it goes here
nothing
great there's
hmm
are there any other clocks in here
zero escapes the trilogy of nine nine
nine nine hours nine persons nine doors
zero escape virtues last reward and zero
time dilemma
i gotta remember where i take things
from
why am i alone today shawshank
because it's a day that ends and why
that's my secret cap i'm always alone
i'm just gonna set this to 10 15 because
i
oh
interesting all right well
that'll make a nice lock pick
uh
i guess there's not really a lockpick
thing happening
gotta look at the clock oh would you
look at the time
oh right that's right thank you
let's pick it up pick it up pick it up
back on the scene crispy and clean you
can try i love how everyone in games
just knows how to pick locks
i found the painting oh
five
well i'm screwed now aren't i
what was that noise
ah
let's put the thing back oh i'm so
[ __ ] i can't let her see i've been out
of bed yeah no [ __ ] i know dude i know
how this game goes
what was that
how did that work
oh great
cool
sewing needle great
what the hell is all that noise you know
what don't sweat it dude
this is terrible this is horrifying
yeah let's do it let's get downstairs oh
i'm so scared
what the [ __ ]
death grinding darkness to the man from
the west the man traveled on he gave his
flesh four beasts of the earth when he
arrived in the east he was charred with
art and joy
death granted darkness to the man from
the west
manchester united slash four beasts of
the earth and when we arrive in the east
he's trying to
earn joy
i'm dead i'm dead oh jesus
oh that is really bad
oh that's oh it's extremely bad
oh that's gross oh that's gross
oh that's gross
oh god
oh that's a
that's a bad way to go that's a bad way
to go
that's a bad way to go i don't i don't
need that i don't need that
i have this thing about like
things going in my mouth
okay just first of all chat don't take
that out of context but you know like in
uh
in um you know prometheus or whatever
when that thing like tentacle goes in
his mouth you gotta do something
like
that stuff is horrifying i hate that
like it's the worst welcome to the
family son
i know lula fawn there's a lot of puking
i gotta put everything back and get into
bed oh my god you have to put anything
back mario
mario alvarez with the all right
i've got to put everything back
jesus that seems like impossible okay
well
okay how do we let's start this again we
take the lantern
all right
i have to put everything back really
all right so i don't want to open that
drawer because
all right
this is weirdly like misery have you
guys seen the movie misery
or read the book it's great
there's nothing in that drawer so i can
leave it that's just a trap
uh
[Music]
the painting stuff can probably stay
right okay oh i see so
the painting is telling us what the
story is
so what stuff do i absolutely need here
i need to take the clock
i gotta take that from the clock right
hey d main i'm doing great i hope you're
doing great too look behind the dresser
says bee mans
oh you know what maybe this is something
what was the thing about that west it
was
the four beasts was the middle one
is there anything with four beasts in
here
maybe this
and burnt the man and the
death came from the
west
and burnt the man in the east
that something like that
all right whatever it'll probably just
tell me what i'm supposed to know
right all right the portrait stuff we're
gonna leave for now i think
but i think we can
can i get back in bed is there a way to
get back in bed
oh i can okay good good good
look for clues man i'm trying is you
wizzy hey edgar's gaming what's going on
having to do with the three paintings
bram uh
bram i think the idea here is i'm
i don't have the clues for that lock yet
okay yeah thanks going all right so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna get
oh this is very tricky all right i love
this game this is great
all right we're gonna get the painting
then we're gonna close it and get back
in bed and she's not gonna be the wiser
it's not time to open the whole thing
yet
what was that
noise oh [ __ ] wait i didn't put the
[ __ ] thing back
oops
i can't let her see i've been out of bed
yeah put the thing back dude there we go
all right right she has no idea
okay
[Music]
what the hell is all that noise
we're good baby we're good uh look i
haven't been anywhere ah look at this
reject
last night is mia no a little fun i'm
not me anymore
i was on the right track before i got
mouth carried this is intense i say
i've got freddy how am i gonna die again
she doesn't know i've been out of the
room
i closed the
lock the notion of she's coming has
never been so terrifying
now hold on just a minute
i haven't touched anything
oh
just my imagination yeah it's just your
imagination don't worry it's all good
please don't spit a bug into my mouth
and kill me
come on now eat up i made that just for
you oh dude you got to figure out it
don't worry
i'll be back real soon yeah i bet
hey lady why don't you get some
electricity in your house
boom all right here we go
all right
can i get out or what's gonna happen
hey ivan uh i'm all alone because we're
gonna start paring down uh
is that a key yeah it's a key dude
all right
so
now
guess we'll start moving the paintings
right or is this just gonna get me
killed
where's the other painting
leave mom alone
food turns you molded got it reed
okay so this works
oh
that's gross look at that
can i close this up or am i [ __ ] here
i'm pretty [ __ ] all right
well
now i'm gonna get murdered
if she comes back
so
i have to
[Music]
everything this game gets you killed
yeah i know dude
how do
i i don't get it all right
bird man
eyes or something
spoon something with the i want to get
the corkscrew for sure
but how do i do that
i got to put the corkscrew obviously in
the lantern cork thing
what would i put there the lighter
the lighter goes there ah okay
it's me hotter
my ex-girlfriend ha ha
moldy mama
look under the bed i know what's under
the bed but the problem is
just take the paintings and put them
back
put the paintings back
oh that's how i close the thing again
okay i see
ah
all right that's good to know
all right because she's definitely
coming back here man
so we gotta tight we gotta keep our room
tidy you know
how do i
paintings in order to poem i did that
though
when you move the bed she comes in again
uh
i set the whole room up fire hmm i need
something hotter than that
to get the corkscrew
i don't want to move there's no point
moving the bed yet i don't think
right
because she's just going to come back in
i think i
i can't put this painting back can i i'm
not touching that
the cone under the bed is a clue to
opening up the door
but i don't i can move the bed back you
say but how do i get this painting back
it's a problem
i don't know that i can
hmm all right i guess i gotta move the
bed right [ __ ] all right
not happy about this but let's do it
let's try moving it moving it back
darkness
four beasts of the earth who's making
that noise so death
[ __ ]
damn it
please put it back
please get in bed
the problem here dude is
close the thing close the thing
that you please lucas i keep telling you
i move the painting though she's gonna
see i move the painting you guys
hey carrot lady
i can't mario i can't put the painting
back i didn't know how to do it
no
is she gonna see the painting
maybe she won't notice the painting
put the needle back
i can't put the needle back
oh i'm screwed you guys oh she's gonna
see the painting
she's gonna see the painting she's gonna
see the painting she's gonna see the
painting don't look at the painting
we're all pals here
there's not a painting under my coat
oh god oh i hate her i hate this
i hate this
i hate this i hate this
i hate this this is giving me nightmares
oh [ __ ] she's going to notice the
painting she's going to notice a
painting
oh please no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
something ain't right no no no no no no
that picture was there in the corner for
don't do the bug thing please don't do
the bug thing oh don't don't do the bug
thing oh god oh god
okay oh god don't do the bug thing
don't do the bug thing
don't you go making me angrier
don't you kill me though
she just leaves
all right
well i couldn't put the i couldn't put
the painting back i couldn't put the it
didn't let me put the painting back what
am i supposed to
do oh you're fine says b-man
oh
now we're in it
i don't want to know that's that's
that's not him
cooking that's not a good thing
spoon
ah there we go
in your face mamma mia look who's out of
bed
this game is basically just like
when my nephew just doesn't want to go
to bed and he just truly constantly
tries to
get the [ __ ] stove okay
oh she she put the painting back all
right fair enough
but guys here's the thing
so this it's the four beasts
of which there is birds right
so here's a bird
four beasts were birds
and then something about being blind or
the baby or something
about being blind or the baby or
all right well maybe the beast meant
this
okay well that's not it
burn the spiders with the stove i will
i'm doing it
doing it lamissa
i just really like that painting mamma
mia all right here we go
stove time
use an item on the stove
uh
it needs fuel come on dude
am i gonna get fuel this
there's fuel in my lantern is that gonna
help
riddle goes to the paintings
the first one is the snake
i'll put the lantern on the stove
can't use that there in your face
go blade thank you nina
what about the last one being the
lantern uh maybe
damn we're so close uh what can we burn
if i have anything in my inventory
no
what can i burn i mean in real life i
would just use the nail polish remover
or i wouldn't care about stupid spiders
can we burn the doll maybe
should we try this again
can we take this
the answer friends is no
um
just for fun i'm going to take this back
so i don't get like asked or killed
you get back secretly
boob thank you started debbie
i have a lighter yeah i know but the
letter doesn't work
oh what's this
oh good well now we can see it death
grenade darkness to the man from the
west right shall we give it
what up ego
one one one burn the house down trying
bro
oh wait a second
got an apple
we got a snake
hmm all right
that's the code for the door
apple snake
he was charred black what would it be
nope
not hoping
god damn it
can i put the picture on the plate since
i put the stove on it no
um
god damn it all right we're close we're
close we're close
we're close it was charred all right
uh god we're so close
we're so close
what else can we look at here
is there something we can use as fuel i
feel like we have everything right
the lighter has something on it
nope
painting no probably not what's on the
back of these paintings nothing
okay
not going to eat that
think about what's being depicted in the
paintings okay
what is being depicted in the paintings
the first one is this one
a bunch of birds eating somebody
second one is a dude going like this
the third one is a dude who's blind
oh the third one is the reaper oh okay
wait a second let's try this
that's why i have it though
unless these are wrong
wait maybe maybe these are switched
somehow
[ __ ]
dude's blind
his eyes
damn it
let's see
no chester fisticuffs is killing it uh
i've your ryo likes my shirt don't be
mad this is by uh a dude in chicago
um
it's called fat tiger works
uh or don't be mad um it's the same guy
or it's like a bunch of friends and
chance the rapper is like he's friends
with chance the rapper so chance wears a
lot of stuff
damn it
think of the story being depicting the
paintings
what is the story it's
a person getting ripped apart
oh wait i'm not doing this the right way
wait a second wait a second this is
wrong
the actual thing is
death granted darkness to the man from
the west
the paintings are in the opposite doors
the manchester united gave his flesh to
four beasts of the earth rather eats oh
wait a second it's the wrong
ah
here we go
i'm stupid i wasn't paying attention
because i was too afraid of eating that
disgusting goo
hmm
ah
here we go
maple leaf
oh here we go okay fork maple leaf spoon
got it that kind of looks like a really
shitty canadian superhero doesn't it
it's like
pancake man or something i don't know
um all right should we take this stuff
down again because she's gonna come back
in
so
fork pancake
what am i talking about i don't even
know anymore
all right here we go
guys i'm sorry but i'm stupid don't ever
be in escape room with me or a life or
death situation what was it the pancake
with or the maple leaf is the center one
here we go
was it apple was in the other one there
we go boom
i'm truly going to be [ __ ] now if she
comes in okay
snake key
oh a little medusa with a snake action
reducing the
serpent although medusa and the serpent
wasn't medusa part serpent what was that
the whole thing
something's going on cork here
this will do this right
okay
i need a knife or something for that i
guess i'll take this out for now but
probably i'll have to put the lantern
there
what is this down here
just cut off blay's arm trying to escape
exactly
oh looky looky
well there's nothing in here
unnerving combat
ah
solid fuel my man all right close it up
gotta keep things nice and tidy so i
don't get [ __ ]
worst stepmom ever on my ass cruella
deville here we go please close the
things
she was cursed and made into a half
snake lady yes she was oh yeah you're
right she didn't start out as a snake
lady she was cursed
ah gods are so petty am i right guys all
right
here we go close the door in case there
are any mold monsters in there
now
here we go with the fuel
i can't use that here
are you kidding me dude
i can't use that here
oh i gotta combine it with the other
stupid thing all right fine
now i can use it there though right use
an item on the stove
in your face it's just more like incense
than anything else all right i mean
there's no
no
oh i'm going out of my mind [ __ ]
can i please take the oh god damn
take the stove
yeah no [ __ ] all right
that's fine
all this stuff is fine
i think we're good man let's put the
thing back on the hook
right aren't we good
are we good
i'm not enjoying this dang it
are we good we're good right
i mean the painting i [ __ ] up again
right
i
i can't do the painting
now hold on just a minute
last time she just threw up on me for
the painting she's not gonna kill me for
the painting this time that picture was
there in the corner for a reason
you're a bad boy clancy
don't throw up with me again please you
were out of bed weren't you you little
piece of [ __ ]
how did you get lost no i wasn't
please chill out give me that i know
when somebody's been touching things
they aren't supposed to oh sexy i love
it when you talk dirty i'm not dead come
on i'm not dead i'm not dead i'm not
dead killer hurt a lot
i'm gonna say it was lucas
no it wasn't me it was lucas he was just
in here a minute ago
it was lucas dude
lucas yeah oh lucas i thought i told
that boy he wasn't allowed to have you
yet oh my god this guy goes from this to
lucas clancy lives a terrible life
yeah
got it ace good game yes
i gotta get out of here before she kills
yeah no [ __ ]
lucas
fapping mr wayne double seven you have
some weird fetishes you're saving those
wine balls for special candy shoes
spiders is a treat
[ __ ] you lucas
eat a dick all right here we go
yeah dog can i just how let's just talk
about this situation real quick how do i
put this painting back here
okay let's just do that right now
because [ __ ] that
i don't need another situation like that
all right
let's use the corkscrew
on this thing
i'm too scared to do anything in the
other room that's going to be like a
permanent thing
uh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
well clearly i need this to light up
eat a dick lucas
you stopped reading lord of the rings to
watch this alimonica
yeah all right
uh i'm nervous though i'm gonna have to
put this back you guys
i think i'm really [ __ ] now i've
really [ __ ] myself here
crouched by the dresser there's
something behind it oh you're right dope
thank you for that
here we go cut it open
i don't know bearski i don't know if if
it's like fallout or not everything is
useful
put that in there
but i don't have one of those things
here
do i
oh you know what ah i bet we can make
okay here we go here we go here we go
here we go kids here we go here we go
um right something like this
kind of
oh no wait i have to combine the two
probably right
there we go all right now let's mix
let's make some
what am i doing
stop it let's make some art baby
here we go this is much better all right
let's make it stupid
uh oops upside down
oh my god i can't
it's making me crazy
yes
no wait i also want to make something
out of the head oh [ __ ]
what can i make out of the head
hmm hey sad vegan
maybe one day pork for the snake
you used a fork for the snake now
that's not gonna work is it
oh wait there's another thing up here
aha here we go
is this gonna work no
it does look like a snake though oh wait
the back of it here we go
here we go here we go
this is i love by the way the mechanic
of this in this game is such a cool idea
i know how these guys thought of it but
it's very neat
here we go
also like why do they make a lock why do
they make a lock like a fork to be able
to do it
it's just weird like who would construct
it like oh i'm gonna make it out of this
fork
i'll take the fork thank you
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah what are we gonna do dudes
no way this is a good idea
uh
oh god
can't use my head be just like staying
here
we're boned
stay in this room oh god
lock the door with the snake key no i
can't do it going to the bed the bed
will open
go to her stabber with a knife i can't
run anywhere you guys
i should have put the hook back after i
finished with it i couldn't dude
no you're right i should have
just do it all right let's go
let's go
step with the knife
stab with the knife get her with the
knife
oh dude that no
please stop screaming
open the thing open the thing open the
thing open the thing open the thing open
the thing oh god open the thing please
open the thing please open the thing
please go down the thing please go down
the thing
run away
run run run
run away
whoo
oh
we did it game on
i love it man
well ladies and gentlemen i think uh
that's gonna do it for today
uh because i don't think there's a way
we can top that ending uh
but thank you for joining us for stream
coco this is great we played resident
evil 7 the band footage uh nightmare and
bedroom uh download dlc
uh run run run away i i do love watching
the uh
i love watching the things on delay here
it's awesome uh well played thank you
abby nicks ace mullet thank you i did
blame lucas by the way
um thank you guys for your help you guys
rule and uh remember check out my own
twitch twitch.tv slash aaron blair we
play a lot more we'll be playing uh
probably either saturday or sunday and
please come back next week on monday at
noon pacific for a little more stream
coco you never know who's gonna show up
here and make sure to watch our show
who's on the show tonight any idea
nobody knows nobody knows nobody ever
knows it's the greatest uh but please
watch our show tonight on tbs and go to
teamcoca.com for all sorts of fun
goodies see you guys next week see you
later bye
you